today
my eyes are beautiful
[Music]
chemistry with Jermaine
watch your needles
[Music]
slept with your main Jackson you just
you just want to sit here and tell me
you slept with Jermaine Jackson Rock huh
Rob is just a guy it's just a it's a guy
you know what I don't know what you're
so upset about we had to see you guys we
didn't agree to screw them Rob
do you love him
do you
he loves me but I'm not sure
that's what it is what it is it's hard
huh
smash everything is so crapping oh I
hate you so much right now yes wake up
Rob I can't hear you
and you know what you know what
thank you you're crazy
Rider
you crazy yeah
so that's it
just like that
I want a family
a husband
kids Faith and family
I love you
we love each other right
and the Bible says oh my no no no the
Bible says no we can go to hell but it's
kind of
I want to go to hell yeah well I'm not
in such a hurry myself yeah well look it
up
look that up
hey
I love you
perpetuity
throughout the Universe
I need my best friend
Jesus
foreign
[Music]
who loves me yeah
yeah I want it you want it yeah it's
about
it's about wanting to dance with
somebody really bad yeah I mean really
really really really really bad and
whatever reason
whatever reason you can't
okay good well I can't wait to see what
you do with it
[Music]
[Applause]
Don't You Wanna Dance
[Music]
it's called
somebody
[Applause]
you also get a bottle of Dom Perignon
from me every time one of your singles
reaches number one on the charts
congratulations
foreign
[Music]
debut album with the most successful
debut solo album in history sweeping the
American Music Awards winning a Grammy
her eagerly awaited second album is
about to be released will she be able to
live up to the world's expectations
[Music]
wow that is crazy
Whitney Houston transcends uh age race
lifestyle sold out so this one has to be
added at 23 she is a true heartbeat of
America
time
for somebody
[Music]
are you pinching yourself yet one more
and you'll have beat the Beatles for the
most consecutive number ones in history
thank you
well
it's a criticism I increasingly hear
from callers that I'm not black enough
your music your music isn't black enough
what would you like me to say the truth
aren't you selling out
a lot of nerves asking me that that's
what my mother tells me
it's a valid question
a common criticism of you and your music
that you're a sellout
that you're not a real black artist
you're about to walk out aren't you nope
oh you'll be walking out before I left
how do you respond
I'm not a black artist when am I you
tell me look I don't know how to sing
black and I don't know how to sing white
either
I know how to sing
music is not a color to me it has no
boundaries
watch somebody that said some dumbass
like that and who said that
that's just Bull and it makes me angry
actually it's hateful and uninformed
I gotta be where someone wants me to be
anyway
seeing what I want to sing be how I want
to be which is big an audience as I can
it's not what our ultimate to do our
whole life she ain't black now she ain't
white enough well how about she's not
obedient enough
how about she ain't fearful enough
well you heard it from Whitney herself
ladies and gentlemen
oh is that too much hell no